on the beaches of Odessa they're
preparing to defend themselves
they know the Russians aren't far away
now
[Applause]
[Music]
and who could have predicted this a
choir provides a wartime serenade to
volunteers
[Music]
everyone here just wants to survive
Odessa is a major port on the Black Sea
strategically important to Vladimir
Putin his invasion though has brought
life to a standstill here and precious
monuments are now shrouded in sandbags
just a little over three weeks ago it
was bustling here you know Odessa is
famous for its cafes and its restaurants
and its sort of Boutique shops but now
it's absolutely deserted and the one
thing that strikes you on every street
corner
are the barricades and behind me is the
famous opera house here in Odessa the
last time it was protected like this was
the Second World War
history really is repeating itself
on the street we meet an elderly couple
and I want to know what they think about
Russia's chances here there's a no-go
Russian army
no ghosts they'll not get through
back in Russia
also Daniel was born in Odessa his wife
and children have now fled and he's
staying to fight
I think you can hold back this Russian
offensive sure we're already shown since
24th that we're holding back and we we
kicked some ass sorry but we kicked some
ass
[Applause]
in odessa's Trendy Food Hall they've
turned it into an aid station Inga a
lawyer is organizing the effort what's
your message to Vladimir Putin all of
that message told the war it's our
country go go away just doing anything
with your Russia everything you want but
never come again Ukraine we hate you and
all the politics we don't need your
support and then a reminder of the
dangers here you almost
so while we were in here about to do an
interview with the air raid sirens have
gone off so everyone's been asked to go
down into the shelter so they're leaving
this area now
a guy grabs a guitar and begins to play
[Music]
no one here knows what's gonna happen
next
Martin Sky News Odessa